peu
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes j'aime la france
oui j'aime la france de toutes mes
forces et de tout mon coeur et même
s'ils semblent dépassées ou ringard de
le dire aussi clairement aujourd'hui
dans le monde politique
je le dis et l'assumé pleinement pour
cette raison je ne peux accepter de voir
notre pays privé peu à peu de sa liberté
et de sa souveraineté au profit de
technocrates qui se croient au dessus
des peuples et de la démocratie
je crois en l'europe mais je ne crois
pas à l'europe de bruxelles
parce qu'elle fait trop de mal à notre
pays trop de mal à nos travailleurs à
nos retraités et à nos services publics
cette europe à dériver vers une forme de
pouvoir oligarchique de plus en plus
anti démocratique qui bafoue nos lois
nationales et profite toujours aux mêmes
les plus gros et les bancs de la cgt au
medef de la gauche à la droite
tous sont pour cette europe de la ruine
pas moi je n'aime pas les dogmes et les
idéologies
je veux que nous ayons confiance dans
notre pays qui est la cinquième
puissance mondiale
oh je sais que nos élites de gauche et
de droite ne croient plus en la france
je sais qu'ils ont même largement
supprimer l'apprentissage de l'histoire
de france à l'école je ne suis pas de
leur bord
moi je crois en la france je crois en
nos talents et je veux la remettre
debout et pour cela je fais plusieurs
propositions concrètes
je ré orienterait en profondeur la
construction européenne vers une europe
raisonnable et utile en europe des
nations libres qui seront lancera dans
les grands projets stratégiques en
remettant à plat les traités européens
qui touche à nos intérêts vitaux
je veux une europe qui protège et non
l'europe de schengen et de l'ouverture
totale des frontières
ensuite je redonnerai une voix à la
france la france est écoutée quand elle
dit autre chose quand elle sort du lot
quand elle s'est affirmée sa liberté par
rapport aux états unis et aux empires de
toutes sortes
souvenons nous du nom glorieux de la
france à la guerre en irak
lafrance quittera le commandement
intégré de l'otan et définira une
politique étrangère indépendante fondée
sur l'amitié entre les peuples et le
respect des souverainetés nationales
nous cesserons les aventures militaires
coûteuse et contreproductive hors de nos
frontières
je pense par exemple à la guerre en
libye que seul j'ai dénoncé et qui a
porté au pouvoir et djihadistes et la
charia jeu renouerait avec la
francophonie pour défendre notre langue
nationale
je porterai le budget de la défense à 2%
du pib d'ici 2017
je crois qu'il faut reconstituer un lien
fort entre notre armée et la nation et
qu'il est très imprudent de nous
désarmer je suis d'ailleurs favorable à
la construction d'un deuxième porte
avions et à l'instauration d'un service
militaire obligatoire pour les filles et
les garçons
oui mes chers compatriotes je veux
défendre la france et construire une
europe utile et non une europe qui bride
qui enfonce équipe unie et parce que
j'aime la france je donnerais
instructions pour que notre drapeau
tricolore flotte en permanence sur nos
bâtiments publics
le temps de la fierté est revenu
[Musique]